empieza el duelo final entre el éxito y
valérie pécresse el diputado del
departamento de los alpes marítimos
sorprendió al terminar a la cabeza en la
primera ronda
representante de la extrema derecha este
especialista en temas migratorios alinea
propuestas de choque preferencia
nacional en el empleo y la vivienda
regreso a los derechos de sangre o
incluso en guantánamo a la francesa para
luchar contra el terrorismo en términos
de seguridad y promete sentencias
mínimas automáticas para los que ataquen
a las fuerzas de seguridad y aboga por
la cadena perpetua y sharp bonsoms un
mensaje de sentido común tocas un
informado y la misma noche duermes en la
cárcel eres un extranjero francia te da
la bienvenida pero comete es un delito
en el país y la respuesta es la cárcel y
partir en avión
en frente la jefa de la región de isla
de francia valérie pécresse que asegura
tener dos tercios de angela merkel y un
tercio de margaret thatcher propone un
referendo contra la inmigración masiva
así como el establecimiento de frutos
anuales la candidata cercana al ex
presidente nicolas sarkozy también
quiere dar prioridad a mejorar el sector
entre sus medidas emblemáticas propone
el final de las 35 horas laborales
libertad para fijar el tiempo de trabajo
en las empresas o incluso jubilarse a
los 65 años este viernes se espera una
segunda vuelta entre los miembros del
partido el nombre del ganador se dará a
conocer el sábado xavi a bertrand michel
barnier y philips urban los tres
eliminados de la carrera a la
candidatura presidencial por los
republicanos ya dieron su apoyo a
valérie pécresse